new face filters on Instagram today this
is my favorite one so far nice job
team this is the
worst all right people that was humanoid
billionaire Mark Zuckerberg I'm regular
human Dave Rubin this is February 1st
2024 we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals the name of the show
is the Ruben report and our theme
today uh is about that Mark Zuckerberg
guy because he was hauled in front of
the Senate yesterday to be grilled on
what Facebook is doing as it relates to
content moderation and child porn and a
whole bunch of other stuff and it was a
freaking circus so why don't we just
Dive Right In uh here is Mark Zuckerberg
being asked by Senator Josh Holly if
there's any connection between young
people using social media and having
worse mental
health with so much of our Lives spent
on mobile devices and social media it's
important to look into the effects on
Teen Mental Health and well-being I take
this very seriously mental health is a
complex issue and the existing body of
scientific work has not shown a cause a
link between using social media and
young people having worse mental health
outcomes all right so there is a big
Tech billionaire saying that the big
Tech stuff doesn't cause worse mental
health for young people and apparently
he has a study to back them up uh I
thought it might be interesting to show
you this from a senate hearing back in
1994 yes or no do you believe nicotine
is not addictive I believe nicotine is
not addictive yes Mr Johnston uh
Congressman cigarettes and nicotine
clearly do not meet the classic
definitions of addiction there is no
intoxic we'll take that as a no and
again time is short if you could just I
think each of you believe nicotine is
not addictive we just would like to have
this for the record I don't believe that
nicotine or our products are addictive
what we did there uh let me start here
because we're going to show you a couple
other clips of of Zuckerberg really
getting grilled uh Zuckerberg you know
most of you have seen the movie The
Social Network people know the story
kind of dorky kid creates Facebook or
sort of half steals it in essence
because he wanted to pick up chicks at
Harvard it becomes this massive thing he
becomes this Elite world power guy who
appears to be a robot he's socially
awkward and and kind of stilted in the
way he speaks and the way he does human
interactions uh but it does fall on him
at the end of the day he is the CEO of
Facebook of meta that is what the
company is called now and it does fall
on him uh if the buck is to stop
anywhere when bad things are happening
on his platforms and of course it's not
just Facebook because Facebook now owns
Instagram and that seems to be really
where particular young girls girls from
about 11 to 17 are getting hooked
getting depressed getting you know
seeing un uh uh uh images that are not
in congruent with the way they can
actually look in real life and that
makes them feel worse and getting
bullied and sexually harassed and all of
those things so I in at some level even
though he's about to get smacked down
for a couple videos we're going to show
you here he did show up and he played
the part I think that's worth a little
bit of credit uh but now let's just
watch him kind of get smack down here's
Josh Holly going after him for the child
sexual exploitation which we all know is
happening on these platforms said you
mischaracterized 37% of teenage girls
between 13 and 15 were exposed to
unwanted nudity in a week on Instagram
you knew about it who did you fire
Senator this is why we're building all
these did tools Senator that's I don't
think that that's who did you fire I'm
not going to answer that um you didn't
fire anybody right you didn't take any
significant it's appropriate to talk
about like IND decisions do you know
who's sitting behind you you've got
families from across the nation whose
children are either severely harmed or
gone and you don't think it's
appropriate to take a talk about steps
that you took the fact that you didn't
fire a single person let me ask you this
let me ask you this have you compensated
any of the victims sorry have you
compensated any of the victims these
girls have you compensated them I don't
believe so you why
not don't you think they deserve some
compensation for what your platform has
done help with counseling services help
with dealing with the issues that your
your servic has caused our our job is to
make sure that we build tools to help
keep people safe are you going to
compensate them Senator our job and what
we take seriously is making sure that we
build industry- Ling tools to find
harmful cont take it off the services to
make money and to build tools that
Empower parents so you didn't take any
action you didn't take any action you
didn't fire anybody you haven't
compensated a single victim all right
there's a couple things going on here
the reason I mentioned sort of the
dorkiness of this socially awkward guy
who starts this thing in Harvard and
then becomes get me the number on what
what's Zuckerberg worth now it's like he
becomes this unbelievably powerful
person running this thing that is
unimaginably ubiquitous in our lives
that has influences on us that we can
see the obvious ones we can see and
plenty that we can't see just by how the
algorithm works and everything else and
it's like if you took that dorky kid
from 20 years ago at Harvard and Flash
Forward him in his life and you were
like oh you're going to billions
billions of dollars and all this
influence and you're also basically
going to be running a platform that is
as Holly pointed out showing
37% of girls I think what was it 13 to
17 uh unwanted nudity it's like man
there is a fouy and bargain there he is
worth Zuckerberg
$141 billion so I think there's
something in all of us that it's like oh
you see somebody that's got all that and
it's like watching him get kind of taken
out to the shed is there's something
oddly satisfying about it there was also
a weird answer there when he says you
know it's our job to create tools to
keep people safe and Holly's like no
it's your job to make money and of
course actually that is his job his job
is to make money the CEO of a car
company his job is not to keep everybody
safe that's a function of the job it is
to sell as many cars as possible keep
the board happy so the shareholders are
happy especially if it's a public
company um should Zuckerberg maybe take
I don't know he's got 141 bill it's
probably not all liquid could he take
500 mil and figure out ways to
compensate some of the young women who
have been hurt by some of this stuff and
by the way it's not just girls although
they were mostly focusing on that
probably could uh but as you guys know
most of these Congressional hearings
they just kind of bring them in they
smack them around and then nothing
really happens uh in the in the real
world although this was an interesting
moment Holly was just going on and just
not letting Zuckerberg off the hook and
they had some of the families of kids
who have been exposed to born I think
who have committed suicide and and just
a bunch of awful things uh and he
basically forced Zuckerberg to get up
and apologize to them right there let me
ask you this there's families of victims
here today have you apologized to the
victims I would you like to do so now
well they're here you're on National
Television would you like now to
apologize to the victims who have been
harmed by your prodct show them the
pictures would you like to apologize for
what you've done to these good
people I'm
sorry knowing should that to go through
the things that your families have have
suffered and this is why we invested so
much and are going to continue doing
industry the efforts to uh to make sure
that no one has to go through the types
of things that your families have had to
suffer all right so it's a bit of a
struggle session there you might say
that's too heavy-handed by Holly
Zuckerberg did get up and do it I hope
he means it forthrightly that the tools
that they've created on this platform
and his his intention was to meet girls
like that was why he created the
Facebook it was called the Facebook at
the time and then it just became this
thing that everyone has on their phone
although I don't have Facebook on my
phone pretty impressive um I do have
Instagram sorry um so he does that and
uh and you might go all right he didn't
know exactly what he was creating it
became so much bigger nobody's perfect
no system is perfect and I'm actually
somewhat sympathetic to all of those
points but then it took a real turn Ted
Cruz got up there and he went after
Zuckerberg for exactly how Facebook has
sort of intentionally allowed children
to see sexual material Instagram also
displayed the following warning
screen to individuals who were searching
for child abuse
material
the these results may contain images of
child sexual abuse and then you gave
users two
choices get
resources or see results
anyway Mr Zuckerberg what the hell were
you
[Music]
thinking all right Senator um the the
the basic science behind that is that
when people are searching for something
that is problematic it's often helpful
to rather than just blocking it to help
direct them towards something that um
that could be helpful for getting them
to get help in what I understand get
resources in what sane universe is there
a link for C results anyway well because
we might be wrong we we try to trigger
this this uh warning or we tried to um
when we think that there's any chance
that the result okay you might be wrong
let me ask you how many times was this
warding screen displayed
I don't know but the but the you don't
know why don't you
know I I don't know the answer to
that there it's like Zuckerberg they got
you they got you we we all get to take
you to resources right so you're for
whatever reason you've searched this
stuff you're struggling I don't know
whatever it is take resources get off
this addiction blah blah blah see
results anyway and Zuckerberg's trying
to say and and as someone that's created
a tech company like I am sympathetic to
all of the issues that arise that you
don't even realize your issues and
everything else but how did they not
realize see results anyway someone
searching for child exploitation stuff
it's like no that should not be on the
platform like they have to have a
department and they do have a department
I believe that it's their job and what a
horrific job and now it can be enhanced
by AI of course so you don't need humans
doing it that have to go out there and
and see this stuff and and make that
judgment call and everything else so so
they really kind of nailed him on that
and Cruz went a little further one more
clip for you
a potential pedophile clicking on I'd
like to see child porn what did you do
next when that happened Senator I think
that an important piece of context here
is that any context that we think is
child sexual Zuckerberg that's called a
question what did you do next when
someone clicked you may be getting child
sexual abuse images and they click see
results anyway what was your next step
you said you might be wrong
did anyone examine was it in fact child
sexual abuse material did anyone report
that user did anyone go and try to
protect that child what did you do next
Senator we take down anything that we
think is sexual abuse material on the
service and we did anyone verify whether
it was in fact child sexual abuse
material Senator I don't know if if
every single search result were
following up on but did you report the
people who wanted it do you want me to
answer your question I want you to
answer the question I'm asking did you
report the people who click see results
anyway um that's probably one of the
factors that we use in reporting and in
general we've reported more people and
done more reports like this to nickm the
National Center of missing exploited
children than any other company in the
industry we proactively go out of our
way across our services to do this and
have made I think it's more than 26
million reports which is more than the
whole rest of the industry combined so
Mr zuer
Zu social media company needs to do much
more to protect children anyway I'm
showing you all of this because it's an
interesting well first off it's catching
fire online and it's an interesting
piece of the of the puzzle that's sort
of wrong with everything right now right
like the material shouldn't be there
there's no system that's perfect you've
got you know congressmen who want
perfect answers to imperfect systems
you've got billionaires being hauled out
and having struggle sessions and
everything else I would say this this
issue in this is the real reason I want
to talk about it it it's basically like
the issue of our time how will we behave
with technology as AI becomes more and
more ubiquitous and you will not be able
to tell the difference between an image
that is a real image or video let's say
of the president saying actually we we
nuked in Mexico yesterday and it's
completely fake and you will not be able
to tell you know right now there are
little little tricks with AI because
it's not perfect yet where you can kind
of tell the mouths don't match perfectly
sometimes there are six fingers instead
of five some weird things like that but
all of this stuff it it's coming it's on
the way and until we figure out how
we're going to relate to all of it and
we know the fact that now we have a
generation at least probably two
generations of young people who do have
more anxiety whose suicide rates are up
and it's not purely because of Facebook
and Instagram and it's also because of
covid lockdowns and a bunch more that by
the way many senators and Congress
people were for uh but we've got this
toxic stew and we've got to figure out
how to extricate ourselves from that
otherwise
border Middle East Ukraine Russia
everything else those are those are
going to be secondary problems to a
society that's just going to be kind of
wandering around uh with a with a really
kind of scrambled eggs for brains and
that I would say is problematic we've
got a Ruben report. locals.com Community
Q&A coming up for you in just a second
but first let me talk to you guys about
gravity def Fire Shoes guys I want to
tell you something that's been making my
days a whole lot easier gravity def fire
shoes these shoes are something else I
mean everyone knows I'm a fan of
comfortable Footwear but these shoes
take it to a whole new level more than
just shoes they're basically clouds for
your feet I'm not kidding in a double
blind study by oliveu UCLA Medical
Center and published in the Journal of
the American podiatric Medical
Association participants experienced 85%
less knee pain it's the most powerful
shock absorption system put into a shoe
gravity to fire has patented versoshock
technology it's like a mini trampoline
in your shoes where whether you're
strolling through the park running
errands or even just lounging at home
these shoes have got your back or I
should say your feet even better they're
stylish you get both comfort and style
that'll look good and feel great and
here's a little extra love for listeners
of the Reuben report go use code Reuben
30 for an exclusive 30% off orders of
$150 more uh $150 or more uh yes you
heard it right a little gift from gy to
your feet experience the miracle that is
GFI where Comfort meets Innovation and
now back to me here we go Ruben report.
locals.com Community Q&A Lano says the
great Republic of Texas existed from
1836 to 1845 was seventh to secced and
didn't rejoin the union the us until
1870 legally we can't secede but did you
know we can divide our state into five
according to our constitution How Deeply
can you see the cleavage between red and
blue States becoming ultimately and did
you think a house and do you think A
house divided can stand is that true
Texas could split itself yes I'm getting
a yes on that they're factchecking
before I'm asking the questions Texas
can split itself into five states well
that would be quite interesting right if
you had four red States and then
wherever Austin is is the blue State
well that that would help in terms of
senators um what wait sorry was the
question do I think secession will ever
happen was that so the question though
was about this division between the red
and blue states which we're obviously
talking about a lot and I think has
really escalated now into the mainstream
like online people have been talking
about this for quite some time you all
know about the mass migration from red
to blue and very rarely from Blue to red
and all that stuff uh but now especially
in light of the Supreme Court decision
on the border Texas sending the National
Guard 24 other Republican states going
in on that you can feel that this red
blue thing uh it's going from just sort
of like this like um esoteric idea that
people talk about to like there's
something concrete really happening
right now do I think A House Divided can
stand you know I've mentioned many times
that what I think can happen ultimately
is the red States sort of do have to go
their own way and by the way they've
been doing that it is very very
different if you live in Florida than if
you live in California if you live in
Texas or you live in New York so states
are doing their own things which which
is exactly the way the Constitution was
set up and The Federalist Papers and all
those things and that is good now the
the more interesting part of the
question is the second part can A House
Divided stand at some point if we keep
going our separate ways and if
ultimately
the federal government does not do its
basic jobs like protect the border and
they just keep demanding more tax money
from everybody and they keep going on
adventurous Wars and all those things at
some point there will be a mass movement
and you can feel it bubbling in Texas
already I would say to a lesser degree
in Florida but some other states as well
like why are we in this Union what is
this Union providing us we are Texans
this is the we have plenty of land here
and plenty of resources and we've got
oil and we've got land to grow food and
we have a set of values here and and
we're we're going to run our own country
like that's not the craziest thing ever
now I would prefer that it didn't and
then I also fear that if the red States
kind of do their own thing the blue
States will never let them go if New
York was like you know what we're
seceding from the Union Florida would be
like hell yeah that was more of a Texas
accident but you get it and and I just
don't think it'll happen the other way
because the blue States will always want
the resources and especially the cash of
the red States and and that is going to
be a real problem so I will fight to
keep the Union together like Abraham
Lincoln but I I certainly understand why
people would give up on the experiment
Veronica says would you ever support an
independent or alternative Party
candidate for local Statewide or
national election uh what would it take
for you to do so well I absolutely would
I mean you know we're stuck in this
unici this artificial binary basically
of Democrats and Republicans I think
there's something super interesting
happening with RFK right now which is
that perhaps perhaps you know he left
the Democrat Party so he's an
independent now you can't get on the
ballot Just as an independent and
obviously being a Ryden isn't going to
do anything but there are other parties
that are on most of the state ballots
the one other party that's on every
single other ballot is the libertarian
party now he's not a pure libertarian
obviously but in terms of individual
rights and in terms of covid stuff
particularly the Libertarians love RFK
so why not if you're RFK just be like
hey I'm I'm just going to take over the
party wouldn't that be something if he
just he said it they they'd be insane to
say no to him right the Libertarians get
check what did what did what's her name
get like less than 1% of the vote last
year I think she got like Point yeah Joe
Jorgenson last election I think she got
like 0 4% or something um and that was
down a bit from what Gary Johnson had
done uh in
2016 so they never get any traction
they're they're kind of a circus of a
party but if he just went in and said
I'm taking over that would at least they
would have to put some of their
differences aside which Libertarians are
oddly not good at uh and then you see
where the chips fall but if he does that
and now he's on all 50 states on all
those ballots the guy could get 25% of
the of the electorate and then the
question is where does that come from on
one hand you could argue that's going to
come more from Trump because that's that
would be like you know the people that
really just sort of hate Trump but
they've kind of had it with Biden so the
disaffected liberal which is what RFK is
on the other hand you could say he's
going to take more from Biden because he
left the Democrat Party and that's
Biden's party Joe Jorgenson did get
about 1% the vote I mean there's just
simply no doubt he could 10x that and
that would be real anyway all that to be
said I absolutely would vote for an
independent I don't really you know what
do I always tell you I'm a Florida
Republican but not a national Republican
and give me give me some good candidates
who basically want the government out of
our life and want some fiscal
responsibility and just kind of I don't
know we'll have roads and cops that
would be pretty good uh Mitchell says
random thought if Biden becomes even
worse as a president and both the left
and the right get mad enough to vote for
the Republican candidate has he then
become the unifier that he professes to
be well that's an interesting question
because you know we played some clips
yesterday of Joe Rogan talking about how
insane everything's gotten on the left
and he hasn't moved and you've all heard
that story before and what I keep saying
is there's this huge huge swath of
people Russell Brand was talking about
this with Tucker there's this like whole
thing happening right now where these
people who have nothing to do with each
other who are not supposed to be in the
same political party are all at least
waking up to the same stuff in large
part because of covid now it doesn't
mean they're all going to vote the same
way but if basically everybody and I do
kind of feel this like how many of you
how many of you out there right now I
would love to know the answer to this
please comment in locals like know
people that really think that Biden is
not only doing a great job but he that
he's really president like meeting the
buck stops with him and this is all
coming from him and that he really
should be running again right now I
don't know that I know anyone that
really believes that I do know Democrats
I know people that voted for Biden
they're all kind of like yeah this is
pretty bad I think they realized uh how
bad it got uh particularly in these last
couple weeks with the Border stuff but
now you see more of the videos of him
breaking down mentally and wandering off
and everything else so wouldn't that be
something if it wasn't a uniting message
on the right that brought everybody
together because Trump's not the best
uniter but it was actually the craziness
of the left that brought everybody
together that would be something uh
Antoinette says do you remember meeting
my nephew at your show you called him
Bahama something uh oh I think maybe I
do he had just recently had his red pill
moment at that show this weekend we had
a family gathering and he was
relentlessly trying to convince my The
View watching mom and sister about the
SOP they're falling for you had a large
part in him waking up uh the Ripple is
growing just thought I would encourage
you to keep up the good fight I'm
thrilled to hear that I do remember I
don't remember oh we have a picture even
yes I called him Tommy Bahama because
that looks like a Tommy Bahama shirt
that's a shirt for a guy having a good
time you know what I mean nobody sees a
guy in that shirt and like he's real
stuff you know stuck up you know
whatever uh that's great to hear I I
love love to hear that and and I hope
that Ripple continues uh Eddie says uh
with all the positive attention going
towards Texas governor Greg Abbott your
thoughts on him being Trump's VP uh you
secure Texas in 24 thoughts I mean it
seems to me Texas which you know a
couple years ago had a weird little blue
moment people thought Betto uh was going
to become Senator and then Ted Cruz just
narrowly beat him but then Ted you know
Betto got crushed in his governor race
against Abbott so it seems like Texas is
solidly red now like I don't think it's
that close so I don't know that's why
you would choose Abbott you might choose
Abbott because he's a pretty good
Statesman and he is leading the front
now with this with this situation
related to the border so there's
something there I mean there's a couple
other guys that I the thing is Trump
needs to widen the net so all I see all
of magas Like It's gotta be Bebe It's
gotta be BC or it's got to be um Kirsty
Nome up in South Dakota you know they
want like the the red meat carry Lake
types like just the magga magga mag but
that's not what you need with Trump with
Trump you need someone that softens the
edges that that maybe brings in some
more Suburban women Etc so I seriously
do think there's still a chance it's
going to be Nikki Haley because the base
will do whatever Trump wants them to do
and if Nikki Haley if she does decently
when by the time we get to South
Carolina in a couple weeks and then
maybe she drops out after that it's like
she was Trump's un Ambassador US
ambassador to the UN and did a fine job
there and it's like oh she will bring in
some of these women she's you know you
may not like her but she's some group of
people that do and those are the type of
people that Trump needs I'd say like
more more kind of like obvious ones that
maybe aren't like hardcore insane magga
but like could widen it a little bit
maybe maybe aan Paul but it's a little
niche to do fully Libertarians that's
probably not going to be it Ted Cruz
would be nice how about Marco Rubio you
take a guy from Florida who you know had
presidential aspirations at some time
you want you guys want to throw in a
name anyone want to throw in a
name you can't do Marco Ruby cuz they're
both from Florida I've been overridden
by my own employee tulsy Gabbert of
course that's the one that probably is
is the most sort of like magical right
because you take an exd Democrat
congresswoman who clearly loves the
country she's pretty she's young the
Democrats absolutely hate her Hillary
Clinton said she was a Russian asset so
she'd love to go off on the Democrats um
I think that that probably gets you some
more of the female vote she's a veteran
um that that might one uh all right
let's see what else conservative chica
says with the push to make the United
States a third world country well
underway what are the languages are you
gonna teach the boys oh man um well look
we are in Miami South Florida there's a
lot of Cubans and Venezuelans here and a
mixed match of other people so there's a
lot of Spanish being spoken here um
sometimes the boys do call water AA at
this point which I think is from our
housekeeper um I guess I mean Spanish
seems like the most obvious one Chinese
probably not the worst thing like I
don't want the world to become more like
China but in terms of like which way the
world is sort of going and being able to
go to another land and speak their
language and the opportunities that that
could present that would be pretty good
Phoenix speaks a little Chinese say
something in Chinese for
me wow and what was that Reuben report
is the best show ever I love working at
the Ruben rep Dave Ruben best boss what'
you say what' you say I said that no but
what was it what translate no I said
sorry my Mandarin is bad but I think
Brock is really pretty sorry my Mandarin
is bad but I think Brock is really
pretty so you can see why I would want
to speak Chinese okay uh Elizabeth says
if you had to teach a skill what skill
would you choose well if it's skills
that I that I actually have I think
probably public speaking would be the
one like I think there's just some ways
to get over some of you know people are
so afraid Seinfeld used to have a joke
about that people's number one fear is
public speaking and their number two
fear is death which means that if you go
to a funeral you'd rather be in the
coffin than giving the eulogy and it's
like I I've never really understood that
I always was very comfortable in front
of a crowd like I feel like especially
if you have the mic you have all of the
Power when I was doing standup I like to
get heckled because I was like you're
not you're not going to beat me so there
are some ways to like just calmly do
things and and to know what you're
saying and not be over scripted and you
know when I give talks like I usually
don't spend much time thinking about
what I'm going to do or have it up you
know like really hardcore planned out I
kind of five minutes before I bullet a
few things in my head and I just kind of
like I can s just sort of see it like I
want to get here and if I'm here then
I'll get here and then I'll get here and
then I'll get here and then I just know
where the end is going to be and I go go
from here to here that's how I do it and
people seem to dig it and appreciate
just someone that can go on stage and
not look at notes you know I've been to
a lot of conferences where guys get up
there podium
they're reading the entire time you get
up there other times people dripping
with sweat people that are stammering
and stuttering and I think I could
probably teach a decent class on that
James says uh you have noted that the
three deceased service members were all
black do you expect that this tragedy
will be used by the likes of BLM to
further their claim that these deaths
prove systemic racism well fortunately
BLM at the moment has kind of
disappeared although it is morphed into
a Hamas organization you know there's
weird thing so these these three
servicemen uh two women actually but
three service people die in in this
drone attack in Jordan about 30 others
injured so there could be more deaths
after that the three that died happen to
be black and it puts everything because
everything is so racialized it shouldn't
matter if a service person dies it
shouldn't matter what skin color they
are but it was just like an interesting
little piece of the puzzle that they
happen to be black it's a Democrat
Administration now is Biden the Democrat
going to escalate the war Democrats are
supposed to be against War but now it's
the Republican party that seems to be
more anti-war than Democrats it just
again it shows that there's this just
like crazy weird connection now of
people that are seeing things a little
outside just the traditional Republican
and Democrat boxes uh Melanie says uh
what did you like about the crown
Netflix series we watched the whole
series because of you letting us know
that you were watching it well I can't
tell if you liked it or not I sense that
you didn't by that question um I like
period pieces I like things that are
based in history or I I usually I like
things that are Loosely based in history
not necessarily like true like
historical Recreations um like Downtown
Abbey I absolutely loved like just loved
loved loved I I do like British uh
period pieces for some for some reason
um the crown I liked because I think
there's something really uh even if you
don't love all of the drama around the
crown now right if you don't love all of
the uh who's the chick and what's his
name the redhead and the chick the
redhead the son who Harry and Megan see
That's how little I pay attention to
these people it's like even if you don't
love all the drama around that there is
something about the idea of the crown
and how it was it is it was and is so
deeply embedded into their society that
it it exists no matter what so the
beauty of the show is that you get to
see Queen Elizabeth as she goes from
being a very very young Queen right uh
because the king abdicated the throne
which is a whole other story which they
go into she becomes a very young Queen
when she didn't anticipate it and then
she end up living into her I think late
' 80s or 90s she only passed away what
was it a year or two ago you see how
Prime Ministers come and go
administrations come and go the country
becomes more left and more right she's
sitting there with Winston Churchill
during World War II and then you see her
with Tony Blair 20 years ago and how the
having something constant kind of keeps
the country alive and it's also like
there's so much Pomp and Circumstance
related to it you can see the tension
between these Uber rich people who have
everything and a country that sometimes
could be in a recession or a depression
and yet still the the many of the people
still love the idea of the crown some of
them hate it how they how do they deal
with with modernizing I mean that was
that's a constant uh theme of the show
how do you modernize in a system that
you believe should be Eternal that you
don't want to destroy as you modernize
it so there's there's a lot of stuff
there I thought the acting was excellent
like they clearly spent a ton of money
the Princess Diana stuff they did a
couple episodes on on when she died and
the family's feelings before that and
after and everything else yeah I dug it
did you like I can't tell Amy says if
you could deify one company what would
it be in why I mean the easy answer here
is Disney right like they should not own
so much stuff that our dreams are
comprised of they shouldn't own Marvel
and Star Wars it's too much right you
want to if you de it's a great argument
for decentralization imagine if the they
were these companies or these products
these these um these stories were
decentralized and then you had
interesting people working on these on
these projects so they weren't hired
because the Star Wars director wants to
make men feel scared and the director of
Marvel wants to show you that women are
ruling the universe and that we have to
push one story from boys and one story
for girls and we're going to teach
people about systemic racism while
they're in a galaxy far far away so
Disney would be the company to deify I
do think uh and by the way um just
yesterday Florida Dan santis won like
officially won all of his lawsuits
against Disney so it's like maybe Disney
has some subtle turnaround but you know
once woke gets into the system it's
pretty hard to get it out uh Christine
says for Lent can we give up the view
and all things Joy uh well I'm not
Christian but you know it would be nice
if for Lent maybe for Lent for for the
lent should we give up Joy bayar and Joy
Reed on the
show all right we're doing Ruben report
L we will not can I really commit to
that no view no not no view just Joy how
about Joy bear no joy bear and no Joy
Reed for a month it's a month yeah you
ask a lot of me but I guess that's the
point that's the point so yes we will
give up Joy Reed and joy bear for Lent
our views are gonna bot them out it's
GNA be sad uh Lloyd says what do you
think of the possibility that print
newspapers will cease to exist by the
end of the decade by the end of the
decade so you're giving them about six
years
um probably not completely uh like
completely completely gone I think
there's something about tangible
something and there'll be a certain
amount of people of a certain age mostly
my age and above that will always
remember that enjoy it you know it's
funny I don't I don't subscribe to a
newspaper here at home but when I'm on
vacation uh especially when I'm going to
the beach I like having a newspaper not
even reading for the serious news but
like there's just something about just
having something you can pick up put
down it's real it's not this thing so
you're not seeing if you're getting
texts and and phone calls and all that
kind of stuff and you're not on social
media um so I don't think they will
completely go away but they they are
crumbling I mean Los Angeles Times it
was a big story last week they laid off
about 130 people um clearly people are
are cancelling subscriptions they're
obviously going more digital uh but I
one of my favorite things to do back in
the day in New York City when I was
doing standup you could buy a New York
Post for a quarter when the days when
you used to keep change in your pocket
and I they would always have the news
stands right by the subway and I'd be
riding the subway and just flipping
through the New York Post and it was
easy to read you could get a little bit
of information and move on with your
life Samantha says Dave Have you
listened to Ben Shapiro's rap song with
Tom McDonald and if so what do you think
about it well as a matter of fact Ben
Shapiro is my guest on the
show Monday uh I interviewed him
yesterday and we talked a bit about the
rap we played some of it and you know
look rap is not my thing you guys know I
like all my musicians named Frank Frank
Sinatra Frankie Valley give me one more
Frank uh I don't have particular
feelings about Frank Ocean but he fit so
um I I'm not a rap guy it's kind of
funny because Ben Ben is obviously not a
rap guy too which is sort of how this
whole thing uh came together but the
fact that it's the number one uh song on
all of iTunes really does tell you
something about culture or about how
people get music or something like that
uh speaking of people in studio we had
Dr Drew my old Californian friend who I
told to leave and now he realizes I was
right he was right here in studio part
one is up right now full thing is up on
locals already new Twitter account on X
rubben report show if you want to get
show clips and we leave you with Hunter
Biden being a creep
[Music]
goodbye